what up guys what a [ __ ] are you my name
yeah no but seriously guys yeah it's
been a while since I've been in the in a
vid it's been since the first rank a
face like four weeks though yeah it's
been that long I've been helping anna
back with editing but yeah with the
school going on it's been hard to
actually make videos regularly but
animax been doing an amazing job and
kudos to him he's been killing it
anyways now it's Christmas time and I
thought what would be awesome as if we
do an anime hall 2016 show you guys all
of the cool anime stuff me an animat got
this year plus we're gonna look at a my
manga collection which it's gonna be
growing but as of 2016 and yeah let's
check it out so guys obviously clearly
our most prized possession dango got
that online on how i expressed and you
know what best purchase I ever made
twenty bucks then we got coming up plush
and a Mac of course have to get calm you
know we all know how much he loves
communist then we got our neighbor
totoro we actually picked that up at
anime north along with this wall scroll
that good I'd log on 1 i've got one
punch man where she she you guys know
these ones because they're always in our
videos code geass ghost in the shell and
of course if you guys been watching
since the pokemon go videos that's from
when we went to the poke a pit stop and
caught that crazy dragonite that was so
intuitive than of course we have a
gurren lagann 5 which you should always
see in our live streams and from anime
north we got this awesome naruto-kun I
as you guys may know by now clannad clad
after story my favorite anime no
surprises there and this is an
especially cool purchase because it came
from my friend and she
japan her name's Tascha and she brought
me back this and you have a bunch of
pictures in there and character designs
and the summary of all the episodes of
clannad 12 25 so I mean this is probably
one of the greatest gift ever which is
not surprising but yeah amazing look at
these beautiful pictures the color too
solid solid ok so starting with Naruto
not all these are from this here just
cuz Naruto I did have before but
instrument I previous videos so thought
it's a good chance to check it out so
we're missing seven and we're missing 11
they'll have 1 through 13 yeah guys so
Anna Mac doesn't really like mainstream
anime that much but she doesn't really
read manga either but like Naruto for me
I mean it's definitely one of those
anime that you know hi it was one of the
first ones I've seen it was also the
first manga I've read before I knew
anything other than dragon ball z
Pokemon before I even knew it was
something called anime my friend in
grade 8 brought a naruto comic like a
shonen jump to class and that was my
first exposure to Naruto and I thought
it was sick and I wanted to know more
and then I eventually got into anime
through death note so next up is death
note I sure I don't have to tell anyone
watching this video how awesome death
note is so we have 126 and that's
because anna mac and his girlfriend get
it for me like every so often they get
three in a row so now they still need to
get me the other six probably for
christmas would be a good time but yeah
I mean you guys know how good how good
death note is it was the anime that got
me at anime I watched all the episodes
and sub before it even came out and
dubbed and yeah and then I
showed it to an iMac and it was for both
of us a very important canim a that got
us into exploring all different kinds of
anime and I mean as a gateway anime you
can't get much better than this this is
the rest of the manga collection so not
big yet I know but it's going to get
bigger and it would help if Anna Mac was
you know antimony could help me out but
whatever we'll build it up quick enough
and hopefully in the future will be
getting a lot more manga and doing more
of these videos so the first one Selanne
Sosa longing is amazing manga definitely
check it out if you haven't already we
have feels galore like this is an
amazing touching romantic emotional
story you have characters who finished
high school and don't really fit in well
with the adult world and with like ah
boring jobs that they're expected to
take on and it's just about also this
relationship between this girl and the
sky and then then the guy has a band and
it is just sweet next is reserved now
you probably all should have heard of
this by now but me and Anna mac yet to
watch the anime but I also know that the
manga is reported to be like one of the
best so I definitely wanted to check it
out here's vol 1 we also have noragami
we have noragami stray stories so I
watched the anime and the anime was was
okay it was good i like a lot of stuff
about I didn't like some stuff about it
but so far what I've read from this it's
funny it's hilarious and it's good and I
like how it's stray story so I don't
actually need all the other noragami so
yeah check that out these mushishi honey
and clover 10 I ordered that off amazon
most of the stuff i have orgoth man's on
and the thing is these two are both
written in French yeah
so but like it was I should have read I
guess that it was in French but it
recommended me we recommended it for me
and I'm like okay this is that it was
actually in French so be careful online
make sure it's in English i'm too lazy
to try to get a refund the hell but
whatever next probably the collection
i'm most proud of honey and clover
complete collection 1 to 10 this manga i
mean it's it's one of my favorites if
you haven't watched the anime or read
the manga check it out it's actually
supposed to be a shoujo like i'll go
into it in another video but i mean the
main character is a guy and that there's
no problem on that front as a guy
relating to it it was an awesome thing
and i usually go back to that manga at
different times of my life and it's just
as powerful every time it's not more
powerful next is orange gotta love
orange read this before the anime come i
came out and I'm yet to actually watch
the anime but the manga was awesome I
definitely recommend it and I love time
travel this wasn't huge on the time
travel but there was an element of time
travel and you know it again like a huge
deals trip it's almost honey and clover
I think you see a common pattern here
among my likes and among speaking of
feels we also have the gods lie so this
is it there's no other kind of parts to
it it's just stand alone manga the gods
lie very good I read this pretty much on
a train ride to my girlfriend's
grandparents house and I couldn't put it
down i read the whole way through and it
was a page-turner and it was emotional
and it was just awesome
next we have lone wolf and cub I've
heard this is one of the best which is
why I got it I haven't started reading
it yet I think it's gonna be a little
weird just because it's from left to
right so I'm gonna have to retrain
myself after learning right to left now
it's just weird and right now I've been
reading bakuman and I just started this
I just finished honey and clover to
Temple and it was amazing and then I
went to bakuman because I just read the
back which says is becoming a successful
manga artist an achievable dream or just
one big gamble so considering that me
and Anna Mac are pretty much try to do
YouTube I could relate I could relate to
this guy and just trying to do something
that you know follow your dreams but
they're being a one-in-a-million chance
of actually you know making a living off
of it so I think that's another one that
just caught my interest I love it when
people challenge challenge conventions
just like Naruto but decide a more
realistic setting and so far i'm loving
and i already read like the first three
chapters and it's great so far and you
gotta know that it's spoiler alert for a
second you got to know that when the
main character proposes to his love
interest in the first chapter and she
says yes you're gonna have a pretty
unconventional mug at the zeta least but
it's super self referential like the
creator of death know and he references
death note in the actual manga it's
hilarious so far i'm loving it
we also have my little monster which you
guys if you know it's a it's a
frustrating anime and extra naruto 5 and
this beauty romeo juliet manga style
check out some of this stuff also read
left right very annoying but you gotta
love i love Shakespeare I love manga so
you know it's not surprising that i
actually was a fan yeah guys I hope you
enjoyed that video and as always until
next time see you space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]